ça y est
robe dessinée par ela
vous avez vu elle se prend pour un
marchand dans son échoppe la devoiselle
cendrillon c'est seulement par amour
pour ton père tué son ami que je
n'accepte sous mon toit et que tu ne vis
pas dans la rue il faut que j'essaie de
me créer ma vie à moi si je vends une
seule de mes robes tout le monde
connaîtra mon
pour que ton mariage s'accordent en même
temps à tva b projet nous allons donner
un bal tu y trouveras une dépose
ce n'est pas souhaitable que tu ailles
au bal je vous en supplie j'ai passé des
semaines à coudre cette robe tout mon
avenir en dépend
owen
permets moi de me présenter je suis ta
fabuleuse marraine est ce que tu vas
aller au bal et rencontrer plein de gens
riches qui vont changer ta vie c'est
justement ce que je disais dans ma
chanson il ya à peine deux minutes alors
cendrillon on va aller aux
hommes c'est différent ça fait jamais
plus ce genre oui mais attends tu m'as
bien dit que tu voulais est une femme
d'affaires la magie va opérer quoi ce
web à que sans elle je perds l'équilibré
un homme un doublement
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai c'est un cauchemar c'est
un cauchemar bonsoir m'accorde
auriez-vous cette danse non
où avez vous trouvé cette robe je les
dessine et est cousue je te choisis pour
être ma princesse mais mon travail je ne
veux pas passer ma vie a salué depuis un
balcon royal pas plus que de rester
enfermé dans une cave
tous
[Musique]
j'ai des rêves que je dois poursuivre
épouser le prince et tous nos problèmes
seront résolus c'est trop tard
[Musique]
ma vraie vie va commencer fort qu'il
tord sept cadres
[Musique]
elles sont au vert ça peut pas être un
peu plus confortable non mais même pas
magique même la magie a des limites
[Musique]